nach regen war das wirklich was geht ab
und herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video ja da hätte ich hoffe natürlich
euch geht's vielleicht haben es die eine
oder andere now fenster schon
mitbekommen da hat sich alex w
ich bin gerade im urlaub hier in spanien
für fünf oder sechs tage und zwar auf
den balearen genauer gesagt kommentare
vielleicht erinnern sich die ein oder
andere noch daran ich bin eigentlich
fast jedes jahr hier und deswegen machen
wir das heutige video auch hier es geht
auch nur hier weil in deutschland gibt
es diese situation nicht ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen ich bin natürlich zufall
darauf gestoßen und zwar war ich vor
letztes jahr 'mal in diesem laden es
gibt nämlich hier vor allem in spanien
auf diesen urlaubsinseln gibt es halt
auf jeder insel sonst supreme shop also
ein supreme laden mit diesen supreme
sachen supreme koffers supreme t shirt
alles mögliche und ich idiot habt ihr
vor zwei jahren mal was gekauft und ja
da dachte ich halt so natürlich krasser
ist auch in spanien jetzt supreme gibt
und dann bin ich wirklich durch zufall
auf irgend so ein youtube video gestoßen
wo jemand in den fake supreme store in
barcelona geht
ich zeige euch das mal kurz mehr korrekt
wenn du schaffst es lieben kamera wäre
echt ah danke
so bildet in der fei primstal barcelona
so ich habe ein bisschen vom spielertyp
ist jetzt hier in barcelona und geht
jetzt zu diesem store
[Applaus]
das ist halt so krass in diesem store in
den er jetzt rein geht der sieht
original auswählen supreme store so
einfach voll 3 ist aber es ist halt
alles fake nichts davon es original und
dass so was erlaubt ist habe ich mich
wirklich gefragt wie das funktionieren
kann so kann mir bitte scharfstellen
zweite mal danke und dieser typ jetzt
genau der das ist anscheinend der
verkäufer der terror auch sonst supreme
shirt an und er will gar nicht dass er
gefilmt und so und das fand ich so
interessant dass ich mir gedacht habe du
gehst heute mal in diesen fake supreme
store hier auf der insel war hier gibt
es auch ein ich hoffe dass es dennoch
gibt der gab es halt die letzten zwei
jahre auf jeden fall diese seite habe
ich dann noch gefunden die wollt ihr
euch auch noch mal kurz zeigen an dem
ich das halt nicht wissen ich weiß nicht
vielleicht weiß auch jeder von euch dass
diese ganzen leben die oder dass es sie
gibt und ich halt alle fake sind bei
supreme italien bzw et lid mittlerweile
auch unter streams streetwear bekannt
und stream von supreme spain handelt es
sich nicht um das original supreme new
york die beiden shops haben nichts mit
dem original zu tun und verkaufen auf
ihren websites sowie auch in den stores
und spanien und italien plagiate die so
ähnlich aussehen wie die artikel von
supreme new york alter krass ein
italienisches gericht hat jetzt
entschieden das ist legal die begründung
die produkte der shops sind in
originalen supreme sachen zwar ähnlich
aber nicht genug um sie als fälschung zu
betrachten supreme kann die rechte auf
das box sogar mit dem wort supreme
blablabla nicht einklagen also da muss
ich sagen das fand ich echt krass weil
das shirt was ich meinem bruder damals
geholt habe war wirklich eins zu eins
wie die originalen sache und der preis
war auch hoch ich weiß dass ich auf den
tisch war aber er lag bei über 50 euro
für sein t shirt da war irgendwie so ein
tiger hier drauf oder so naja mehr
möchte ich auch gar nicht erzählen wir
fangen jetzt los zu diesem laden und
dann schauen wir mal was passieren wird
ich versucht ein bisschen zu film und
ich frag doch mal die mitarbeiter auf
das fake ist oder was genau
dahintersteckt und dann sehen wir uns
gleich in meinem flitzer hier wieder ich
habe so ein kleines auto das gleiche
so leute wir haben irgendwie so ein
smart oder so ganz komisch oder habe ich
vorher noch nie gesehen auch viertürer
und ich weiß erst mal warte mal ich kann
ja eigentlich ein bisschen heller
stellen ich muss jetzt erstmal so
ungefähr 15 minuten fahren und ich hoffe
wirklich dass es diesen laden noch gibt
wie schon glaube ich erwähnt ich war da
dies ja noch nicht letztes jahr habe ich
den mal gesehen ich war allerdings nicht
drin deswegen ich bin mal gespannt was
mich da erwartet ihr seht schon ich bin
ziemlich am schwitzen als fucking heißt
hier drin wir fahren jetzt los wir sehen
uns dann gleich alle leute das immer das
beste hier eine schaut nach vorne diese
straße ist so eng man braucht hier mal
wie ich muss jetzt erst die vorbei
lassen damit ich überhaupt weiterfahren
kann
also willkommen in spanien viele leute
ich bin angekommen ich nehme die kamera
natürlich mit aber ich nehme auch mein
handy mit weil ihr kennt das von meinen
videos so das schlechteste restaurant
oder so da habe ich auch mal nur mit
handy gefilmt damit es nicht so auffällt
und ich glaube das mach ich hier heute
auch also schau mal ich hoffe halt wie
gesagt diesen laden gibt es noch und
dann zeige ich euch jetzt mal und ich
bin mal gespannt was mich erwartet aber
jetzt glaube ich schon zum zweiten mal
gesagt let's go so weil man jetzt hier
um die ecke geht
wo war das ist okay leute also folgendes
ich war gerade an so einer anderen
location wo das meiner meinung nach die
letzten jahre war dieser laden war aber
leer und ich dachte mir schon so okay
gibt es nicht mehr
und jetzt habe ich mal ein bisschen
weiter geguckt und hab gesehen dass die
anscheinend umgezogen sind ich will mal
von hier ein bisschen da kann man es
sehen und da gehen wir jetzt mal rein
also da hängt halt auch oben dieses
supreme schild dran und ja ich würde
jetzt auf mein handy kann sehen wir uns
darin okay ich dokumentiere das jetzt
mal ein bisschen für euch nach hier seht
ihr dieses problem logo das steht halt
vor dem laden und so sieht das
schaufenster aus alles produkte die es
im originalen gibt wir hatten ja gerade
schon diesen koffer diesen basketball
und diese ganz habe ich da auch gesehen
und jetzt bin ich halt rein gegangen ich
habe das ganze ungekannte gelassen also
uncut und ich rede gleich auch noch mit
der verkäuferin
ich wollte mir jetzt die erstmals einen
kleinen überblick verschaffen und habe
mir dann so t shirts angeschaut und das
waren halt alles t shirts für 50 euro
also jedes feature das glaube ich 940
euro oder 9 50 euro kostet mit diesen
supreme 49 hat das gekostet und dann mit
dieser supreme aufschrift da oben und
ganz kleiner drunter steht supreme spain
also das ist der einzige unterschied
wohl dann daran ich weiß es auch nicht
genau genau kann ich mich auch nicht aus
aber da oben seht ihr jetzt diese ganzen
pullis und all diesen originalen stuff
diese taschen die kennt man ja
eigentlich ja die waren eine zeitlang
übertrieben und jetzt gleich kommen wir
zum absoluten höhepunkt meiner meinung
nach können wir dieser koffer kostet
einfach 550 euro 5 fucking fei koffer
eigentlich der andere hat 419 kostet
dieser schwarze und ja da sagte ich mir
so alter mann dass jemand kauft also es
ja an sich abzocke die haben wir noch
ein rucksack
also da gibt es gab es alle möglichen
sachen und jetzt gleich aber ich glaube
ich die verkäuferin an hier noch ein t
shirt für 5 95 euro kann das sein das
war so ein pulli keine ahnung okay
wir sind leicht
aber ich war so leute jetzt habe ich
idioten mich auch noch dazu entschlossen
socken zu kaufen
sheikh socken eigentlich für 20 euro die
haben wirklich 20 euro gekostet und ich
muss sagen ich finde das wirklich extrem
krass weil ihr habt's ja gehört diese
frau hat zwar gesagt so das ist halt
einfach nur supreme spain aber an sich
ist es ja einfach nur dreist coupé und
dann auch noch so genau die gleichen
sachen so denn genau den gleichen
preisen anzubieten
finde ich schon heftig ich hoffe ihr
könnt mich gerade verstehen wegen dem
wind auf jeden fall hatten wir ja so
einen koffer am anfang und dieser koffer
hat einfach 550 euro kostet das muss man
sich mal vorstellen den fake koffer und
diese ganzen touristen die hier
hinkommen und davon keine ahnung haben
wo dann die kinder so sich denken borste
primgeiger wollte schon immer was von
haben und dann kaufen manche den 1
diese fake sachen die zwar genau so
aussehen aber im internet haben wir auch
gelesen die qualität ist deutlich
schlechter und bla bla bla und dass das
dann hier auch noch von der regierung
sozusagen geduldet wird finde ich schon
heftig also in deutschland hat das die
anscheinend nicht geklappt und ich habe
jetzt einfach 20 euro bezahlt für diese
zeit socken einfach und die gleich mal
danke man einfach um ihr die gleich mal
anzuschauen das papier steht wieder mal
ein geiles smartmobil was ich dazu
nämlich auch noch sagen kann ich habe
meinem bruder mal von diesem alten
supreme star wurde noch an der anderen
adresse war habe ich immer für 50 euro
und t shirt gekauft und sogar oder ein t
shirt für den weiteren freund
mitgenommen das heißt ich habe da mal
100 euro ausgeben für seine fans scheiße
das war vor zwei jahren einfach weil ich
das überhaupt nicht wusste ja naja je
älter man wird desto schlauer wird man
auch und hier steht das halt auch direkt
supreme und an darunter leicht klein
spain erhält ist wir nicht so heftig
dass wir genauso wenn ich jetzt einfach
zum beispiel louis vitton kopieren würde
genau die gleichen sachen zu genau den
gleichen preisen so ganz klein germany
unterschreiben würde das wird ja nicht
funktionieren und ich frage mich halt
wie zu fig das hier funktioniert dass
das halt legal ist die haben ja einfach
stores auf formentera wo ich bin auf
ibiza gibt auch sonst de barcelona
madrid alles ist voll mit diesen fake
stores futuristische arsch werden so
okay ich habe mich jetzt genug aufgeregt
wir freuen uns erstmal zurück
okay leute mittlerweile wieder zurück
als er diese kamera stellen ein bisschen
schneller scharf bitte ich hab ich das
ja gerade im auto schon gezeigt komme
hier haben wir dieses supreme socken ich
wollte gerade meinem internet suchen ich
habe sie nicht gefunden vielleicht liegt
das daran weil es die gar nicht gibt
keine ahnung das war ja auch noch
heftiger wenn die einfach so neue sachen
erfinden als supreme fake unternehmen an
die sich auskennen schreibt ihr gern mal
die kommentare hier gibt es allerdings
socken für 25 euro
die fake sein aber auch schon 20
gekostet für fake socken also obwohl
eigentlich könnte ich die noch mal kurz
anziehen so sehen die aus ich weiß nicht
ich sehe aus wie der weihnachtsmann aber
gut also kennt ihr diese socken gibt sie
wirklich lasst es mich in den
kommentaren wissen was mir auch noch
aufgefallen ist dieses supreme läden die
wollen dass das internet gar nicht weiß
dass sie so existieren meine meinung
nach weil das hier ist die adresse also
die muster bestehen von dem laden aber
da gibt es keinerlei fotos oder
bewertung zu
das gleiche gilt für die shops in
barcelona da kann man die adresse sehen
aber irgendwelche bilder gibt es da
zunächst hatte jedoch dass hier aber gut
ja ich finde das immer noch so heftig
dass das funktioniert und es
funktioniert verdammt gut glaube ich vor
allem jetzt hier wo so viele touristen
sind die das alle nicht wissen schreibt
über gerne mal eure meinung dazu in die
kommentare
und wir sind uns dann morgen wieder 19
uhr gibt's neues video wir jetzt jeden
tag volkmann instagram 30 alex p check
die videos auf die letzten teile kamen
würde mich freuen und das war es von
fake supreme store ich wünsche euch
einen schönen abend haut rein